well obviously the situation we're
facing at the moment on energy is is
challenging but as you think you said in
your report the uh uh although the
increase in the price cap which is
obviously an independently assessed cap
that's put in place or reviewed every
every six months means there will be a
rise it does still mean that uh through
the winter because obviously it'll
persist now um all those households will
be protected uh from the full impact of
the rise of gas and indeed if the prices
rise uh any further but look we
recognize the the challenge that people
are facing that's why it's very
important that we get the economy back
up and running as fast as possible it
seems to be growing strongly and
hopefully we'll
reach karma times quite soon so what's
your advice on people to people who have
to choose between heating and eating
well obviously you will also have seen
yesterday that the government announced
a 500 million pounds uh fund uh to
assist uh people who are experienced
that kind of hardship uh the details of
how that's going to be administered will
be publicized soon and once that becomes
available then i hope that those people
who are in that unfortunate position
will avail themselves of that assistance
yeah uh it's still not going to be
enough though is what we're being told
four million people in fuel poverty do
they feed the kids or switch the
radiator off
well obviously the as i say the
government's putting half a billion
pounds out there to assist people who
are in that challenging
situation and obviously the of
through universal credits although
obviously the 20 pounds is coming to an
end but
through universal credit what we hope is
that that will assist many people to
maximize both their support from the
government but also what they're able to
achieve through working if that's what
they do so we'll keep this under review
but as i say at the moment at the cap at
the level it's set does protect people
from further rises in the energy market
you need to look again at this 20 quid
don't you for universal credit being
taken away
well that uh the chancellor's obviously
reviewed that on a regular basis over
the last few uh
months it was a temporary measure
brought in as part of the
covid uh effort uh to help people
through that particular uh difficulty
what we hope now is that as we see
employment rising very significantly in
the country there's obviously a lot of
vacancies as we know that people uh can
try and fulfill if they have the skills
available
they'll be able to get back onto the
steadier time should we say from a
financial point of view
thankfully the petrol station uh issue
is easing or is it um petrol station
bosses accusing the government this
morning of gaslighting the public um
where is the fuel
so as i understand it okay the the fuel
supply into the country is not the
problem there's obviously a distribution
issue that's caused by excess demand if
you like as far as we can tell uh
certainly my information this morning is
that the situation is stabilizing across
the the country uh albeit there's
obviously still high demand for
for fuel let's hope that over the next
few days that eases as people
you know as their tanks fill um and that
extra demand starts to abate a little
and we can get back to a more
predictable pattern of supply
what is why is there a why are we saying
i suppose a mr mulhouse a postcode
lottery if you will of fuel you know um
if you're in the city um london
birmingham manchester it's incredibly
difficult to get fuel and you have to go
past maybe ten um petrol station four
cores before you managed to get some
yeah well as i say okay i'm not close to
that effort i've been uh sadly
concentrating on some of the awful
stories that we've seen uh recently uh
to do with the the police
but i do know that there's a team at
bayes that's monitoring the distribution
of fuel across the country uh they're
trying to assist the industry to get
back to a more predictable pattern of
supply obviously demand for fuel across
the country is not always predictable
that comes and goes
normally that is a little more certain
but in these in these times where
consumer behavior
allied with a perception of a shortage
of fuel is driving different levels of
demand obviously we're having to move
quite dynamically to address that and i
know they're working very closely with
the industry to try and ensure that we
get supplied back onto a stable footing
as quickly as possible so it's the
motorists and the messenger smart um no
that's not what i said okay i said
there's a there's different patterns i
said there's different patterns of
demand at different times in different
places and that is at the moment not on
the same predictable pattern that we've
seen in the past now efforts need to be
buying more fuel than normal well yeah
that is the case people are um and
people are naturally responding to what
they see and what they hear and what
they feel now i don't blame them for
that people have important journeys that
they have to make people have a you know
they're required to get to work get
their kids to school all those important
things they need to do but as i say what
we're trying to do is to say to people
look if if we can return to a normal
pattern of consumption then we'll return
to a normal pattern of supply and there
is no problem with fuel coming into the
country yeah and the way to calm
people's nose is to get a few um drivers
with their army fatigues moving fuel
around the country that'll count
people's nerves why have we not done
that before now
well obviously there is work that's gone
on around the resilience of the fuel
supply and putting people on on standby
but as i say that there's only so many
tankers there's only so many drivers
there is no shortage of supply at the
moment into the country the question is
the distribution and there's lots of
effort going in to make sure that we get
that patent stabilized people can get
the fuel they need for the important
journeys they need to make
and hopefully as i say in the next few
days things will stabilize further and
return to normality in short order